[Música]
es un tema - la edad de los lugares
en todo el mundo las grandes ciudades
documental y el de testigos visuales
Delaware es una de las grandes ciudades sin
la duda se da cuenta de los mínimos y los qualys
todos los está decepcionado pero estamos
gerentes y equipo en kvc tenemos
alquiler de los greens que nuestro profesor
pero tenemos muy pocas oportunidades de
ver
[Música]
un grupo de científicos llamado
grupos de trabajo que hacen
investigaciones sobre nuestro tiempo y grupo de
trabajar en el antropoceno para ser un
motivación ya que se trata de volver
el after y hoitz ko moss old of the
planeta a como un pc cena concierto
como Presidente de los Ejecutivos Históricos
tierra a la tierra nosotros que
de lo contrario, sirve a la porción del cielo, pero su
significado y cientifico
fascinante para nosotros tratar de hacer
el lado visual visual la respuesta
investigación visual de este grupo de
científicos
[Música]
la ambición del cine es dar
la oportunidad a los videntes la misión
documentos talento es ir allí
reflexiones públicas casuales
en los suburbios exteriores y el sábado en
italia en el planeta se ve bonito movimiento
como esta semana y podría
miss timo notablemente el jackpot boy
asi que bing clemente a entrenar
reflexiones y transformación y que el
transformación severa de karen siete
cambios de conciencia en acción
[Música]